over seven years six million refugees
have fled the devastation in Syria
children make up more than a third of
that number
many have witnessed horrifying tragedies
but even in the grimmest of
circumstances there is hope I've been
invited to the Bekaa Valley in Lebanon
to meet some extraordinary young refugee
musicians who have been given a
once-in-a-lifetime chance to perform in
Lebanon's capital Beirut
[Music]
till there is a Japanese man
I shall
music is there a secret of life Okuma
and scar Pasolini for holiday removed on
the farm
[Music]
where I'm driving now has been described
as one of the most beautiful places on
earth it was a breadbasket of the Roman
Empire and it's been home to some of the
world's very greatest civilizations but
over the last few years is also seen the
passage of over a million Syrian
refugees and half of those are children
and many of them are very very
traumatized
[Music]
I'm just a few minutes from the Syrian
border here and Damascus is just beyond
me over those mountains and this is a
little cultural center the action for
hope cultural center where kids and
young people come from camps right
across the country
every weekend to learn music this music
school is run by action for hope and
funded by the British councils cultural
Protection Fund here musicians and
volunteers teach traditional Syrian
music to refugee communities thank you
would you like to see this I would love
to thank you
I've had seen some cases how many do you
have here how many students 24 and they
come every weekend yeah I can hear some
drumming obviously but what else do you
teach them here saxophone singing I
would booze up yes some wood and cello
oh you Lena so I know some of the kids
have had a very tough time yeah before
they came but does it help them becoming
here do you think yeah I think there's
[Music]
the organizers believe that teaching
traditional Syrian music is a powerful
tool to combat trauma whilst ensuring
cultural heritage isn't lost
Heba the music school ensembles drummer
never misses a beat in this order we
have only has a fellow fat and effective
national anthem thank you Heather's
house is in fact a plastic heart her
family are desperate to return home to
Damascus but feel it's still not safe
love you to see should I take my shoes
off instead like many makeshift camps
have become a semi-permanent home but
involvement in the music school is
benefiting this whole family was was
music a big part of your life then Jana
conative surah al maseeh and on our
family allowed us a flat solid Mahone
and mustafa ala ali about solemnly heart
Salim phenomenal mosaic are numbered
actor do you think music can help to
bring lots of people together as a
society as a community yeah inaudible
I'm addressed 11 element Madoff McTeer
my daughter Janna fellows woman huddle
members the Maserati bhatooras mudra
still mercy are here of a Tamela Holly
Yahoo dunal have fled we are tunable vo
main ability
abscessed assyrian music connects these
communities to a culture they've had to
leave behind learning music restores a
sense of self-worth belonging and
identity as well as introducing young
people to a profession that might be of
practical benefit in the future
[Music]
Thank You Japan by her mercy bye
[Music]
well what an extraordinary privilege to
be welcomed into that home but isn't it
just heartbreaking that the one thing
that Heba and her mom and her sister and
her little siblings want to do is to go
back home and see their loved ones and
home is just the air you can see it's
just beyond the mountains but they know
that they can't get back there safely
but at least they think that music is
something that they've taken from this
experience it's one tiny tiny fragment
of a silver lining I'm going back to the
music school to listen more closely to
the traditional Syrian music and theory
the students are eager to learn every
weekend these young people are from
different places most Assyrians some
Lebanese from areas of the Bekaa and
some Palestinian refugees from camps in
Beirut what they have in common is their
love for music it's this which brings a
sense of focus and unity in what is for
some a splintered existence
this is Ibrahim from Aleppo in Syria
he's been learning the accordion for two
years helping him to overcome the trauma
of losing close family relatives during
the war
hi sorry sorry to interrupt hide the
sounds fantastic
Ibrahim beautiful amazing turnout I'm a
farmer's of the other leg is missing me
the husband has died no one had it and
did I walk listen we'll see that some
are thoughtlessly of us wow you want to
carry on playing the accordion when you
when you return home but they don't come
until mother remove the harness but
they're not what was their habit either
do you think coming here and learning
about the beauty of music does that give
you more hope for the future
dad oh yeah remember the pendulum also
tripped boy so to have new mama
well thank you for bringing us the music
it's beautiful it certainly makes us
very happy
Thank You chakra music plays a huge part
in Abdel kouddous young life for him
music isn't only a reminder of home it
is home
[Music]
come to hear Anna Soria I can ombre blue
or vastly mostly ash led by young music
Olivia how did Anna I'm chef today I'm
shocked to our table T d'Italia
abdelkader often plays with his father a
man he wants him to remember that music
from their homeland to some of the
oldest in recorded history
[Music]
[Music]
I'm very well how are you I'm Bethany
Bethany thank you hello again hi are you
doing you look really slowly
who hi any Arab Nam in Ho Chi Minh Liam
didn't let Angie be out far either one
Sathyan Hallett mode kathira been NASA
we will believe Haley second EFI
hustling in Elmo Amana and you were an
[ __ ]
r24 how worked in the energy at Farley
and she do you think it helped your
family as well the fact that your family
are all musicians to do you think it
helps your son and your other children
Howard in the M&A lightly hates in silly
Halina me about money altogether
my bad na na Mele very shallow very low
access hello Michelle
Tattaglia - the Parliament owners had an
other rocky who tears are the tombow
tejanos the husband Musharraf eat hot
and if you cannot fallen in Manila horn
and like you brew any insu's whale ham
will Monsieur witnessing this and and do
you find it if you ever feel sad or
stressed yourself does it make you more
happy as well to play your music and
certain to live in the world of music
Lucia
barely hear or see an Italian Emily oh
habit al khattab Liana la batalla
animosity Oklahoma landscape has her
Lanie for Hanukkah t removed on the fire
Oh accessorize I know is a very
beautiful thing on a Friday night back
in Beirut it's time for the school's
ensemble to showcase their skills in
front of a live audience
the event is part of an Arts Festival
and our young musicians have been given
a prime time slot for some this promises
to be a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
to show their talents to the world is
near Arras ooh
magellanic dheere chalo Papa samanaú
someone has a big
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well done well done that was fantastic
[Music]
it's a very long way from home
forming in an abandoned Factory in
downtown Beirut to a whole crowd that
they've never met before and giving them
the time of their lives in fact doesn't
tell you about the power of music
these children have endured one of the
most brutal of Wars and witnessed things
in their short lives that few adults
ever will
[Music]
no one can know what their future holds
but at least now there is a chance that
music will be a part of it
[Music]
you